Returning to our digital tracker, remember that we were still left
with the problem of busy waiting. We were wasting CPU cycles, just
waiting for another thread to change the value of the variable.
We're going to solve this problem, by creating an additional weight variable. So
the code will look like this. Instead of having a wow
loop and whether the condition is met that does nothing, the wow
loop now makes a call to cond_wait. CPU's cycle save. The
second thing to notice is that the new text variable is back,
and it gets passed in along with the conditional
wait variable into the cond_wait procedure. We do this
because we want to make sure that the condition,
in this while loop still holds when we put the
thread onto the wait variable Q. The nightmare scenario
is that in between this check and the call to
cond_wait, another thread changes the condition and sends the
signal. Then we could be waiting for a signal that
might never come. So it's a good practice to lock
variables that might cause the condition to change before you
make the cond_wait call. The cond_wait method itself puts the
active thread on a waiting queue, and then unlocks the
new text so that another thread can change the condition
we are waiting on. When the conditional signal comes, the
method then reacquires the box before returning, that's why we
need to unlock it again down here. Now, somewhat surprisingly,
we need to recheck our waiting predicate that is, is bufavail
equal to zero again before moving on. That's why we have
the while statement here instead of an if. The reason for
this is that we might not have been the first thread to
acquire the lock. Another thread might have acquired it first and
changed back the condition to something where we would need to
wait again. In this digitizer example I guess maybe that would
be another tracker. Putting this in a while loop so that we
recheck the predicate after the signal comes is called rechecking the predicate.